[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's God.
It's God.
>> The word God has the article and savior
doesn't
personal and secret. You
>> like to tell us why you're Muslim. But
the problem is that we reading the
Muslim.
>> Okay. Have you have you're Muslim? Tell
us tell us why you're you're Muslim. Why
would you say you're a Muslim today?
Because you are worshiping one God.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> I I believe I worship one God.
>> So you are Muslim then?
>> No way.
>> So
>> I say Jesus is a god.
>> No, Jesus is not a god. He's a prophet.
>> So So I guess the difference is is that
if I say I worship one God, right, but
Jesus is my God, I'm not a Muslim,
right?
>> Say it again.
>> That if if I if I say I worship one God,
>> but the God that I worship I say is
Jesus, I'm not a Muslim, right?
>> No.
See, let me say something. Go ahead.
>> The God only one.
>> Mhm.
>> Jesus, Muhammad, Moses, all these
prophet sent by Allah subhana tala.
>> Uhhuh.
>> So how come that someone human like me
and you
>> become a god?
>> Do you do you believe God is all
powerful?
>> Believe in a god has what?
>> Do you believe that God is all powerful?
Like he could do anything. He
>> is.
>> So do you believe if God wanted to?
Yeah. Could he come and take on a human
form if he wanted to?
>> Yes. But not the way you are talking
about and he want to send it to me the
message.
>> No, it's not.
>> Well, so so what I would say is that
what what I what I believe as a
Christian, I believe that God, he's able
to do anything. And so one day he told
us that he's going to come in human
form. And that's what Jesus is.
>> I will not be like human form.
>> Why?
>> Because he's a god. He's a creator.
>> Yes. why I will not come from the from
the heaven or from the sky to down to
earth and say okay I'll be in the form
of the human just to see the my uh
people how to worship me.
>> Well, no not that that wouldn't be the
reason. I would agree that that's not a
good reason for him to do that. But
according to the Bible, there's a reason
why God will come in a human form
because one, he he represents mankind
because we can't do it ourselves. Let me
tell you this. Yeah. See
The God is the God. Okay. And one of the
miracle things is Jesus. Jesus when he
came in the earth.
>> Uhhuh.
>> He without father,
>> right? Born of a virgin.
>> Yeah. A virgin.
>> Okay. So there's more than miracle than
Jesus. Which Adam?
>> Well, no.
>> Adam came without without father,
without mother.
>> But Adam wasn't born.
>> Wasn't born. Yes.
>> Yeah. So he he was made, right?
>> Okay. So which this is what I'm telling
you.
>> Yeah. which is difficult to bring
someone it's not a neverb born or to
bring someone someone he born from the
Americ
I I don't think for God I don't think
anything is difficult
>> yeah it's not
>> yeah it's easy for him
>> what we are telling we are believing in
Jesus we are as a Muslims we believe
Jesus is one of the best and perfect
prophets
>> so let me ask let me ask you why
>> that's why we love we love him we love
Jesus more than anything else
>> yeah but you're missing a key part to
Jesus, you know, like for example, why
was Jesus born of a virgin? Like why a
virgin?
>> The reason?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Because Allah subhana t was sending a
message to
to the Jewish.
>> Yeah. But why? Why a virgin?
>> Huh?
>> Why a virgin though?
>> That's the god willing.
>> So, but see
>> the god willing
that mean he's his son.
>> But there's a reason though, right?
>> What's the reason? Tell me. What's the
reason?
>> See that? And that's the point. So like
when it when it comes to Jesus, like
he's you believe he's Messiah and stuff
too, right? With with the Messiah, the
the one to be born is through the
virgin, that's the purest way to be
born, right? Without being defiled,
right? No, no man touched.
>> So So the reason why is because the
Messiah being born of a virgin is
actually God with us coming to be born
as human to represent you and me.
>> It doesn't make sense. So then why so
why don't you sit and sit down?
It doesn't make sense.
>> Let me say something about it.
>> I I would say doesn't make sense. You
said look
you said that Allah has like attributes
right? He has 99 names right? Allah has
99 names.
Not not Allah is 99 names but this is
description of Allah like like he's a
patient for example like he's the
forgiveness
>> yes these are attributes
>> this is not the name this is what they
call it I don't know what they call it
in English but it's we call it titles
>> we call it like a titles
>> attribute what's your name
>> my name is Avery
>> AL let me say
>> if I see this guy I said oh he's very
good guy.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Uh he's very nice guy.
>> Uhhuh.
>> He is very genius guy.
>> Yeah.
>> All these names, doesn't that make you
make you a god?
>> I understand. But with with with Allah's
names, does that make him go?
>> He's a god without that name.
>> Okay. So what what makes
>> we believe in that he's God? Because see
see the see the sky. See everything
around you.
>> So the creator would that be a name of
him?
>> Huh?
>> Would would the creator be a name of
God?
>> Yeah, it's he's Allah.
>> Allah. Okay. Right. So that would be
like one of his names.
>> Yes. One of them is Allah.
>> Okay. And so now when we're talking
about Allah and saying that Allah he's
the creator, right? He's the sustainer.
He's all knowing. He could do anything.
Right? These are all descriptions of
Allah. Right. Yeah.
>> Now when you talk about these
descriptions with Allah, these same
descriptions are are about Jesus.
>> What is that description about Jesus?
>> So it says so Jesus says that he's the
one who gives eternal life. Huh?
>> He's the judge that's going to judge and
judge the dead.
>> Giving eternal life.
>> Even Muhammad. Even Muhammad. Yes, he
did. That's mentioned in Quran.
>> No, no, no, no. I'm not saying raising
the dead. I'm saying giving eternal
life. Like you determine goes to heaven
or hell.
>> He's not giving but Allah subhanaa.
That's what he says.
>> Listen. No. Quran saying clearly Allah
subhana wa ta'ala he's telling Jesus to
make this creation for the baby or for
whatever. Okay. that to tell Jews, okay,
I'm the prophet of Allah and Allah help
me to do this.
>> The same thing has happened with with
Moses himself. Moses himself, he made
the sea. It's two parts.
>> Yes. It says God did
>> when he was when he was
>> from Egypt. It says God did
>> Jesus done it.
>> Uh Moses done it.
>> No, no, no. So, so Moses So God Moses
just followed God's instruction.
>> The same thing with Jesus.
>> No, no, no. With Jesus, he said no.
Jesus, he spoke to the girl like he told
the girl she was dead. She was uh not
alive anymore. And he spoke to her. He
said, "Rise."
>> Jesus rose her.
>> Wait, wait a minute. Wait a minute. When
he said rise, he said by by name of
Allah.
>> No, he doesn't.
>> He is.
>> No, he is.
>> He doesn't say that.
>> It is. It is. I didn't read the Bible by
the way. But I'm sure I'm sure because
I'm hearing here and there and I'm, you
know, listening to the a lot of people
that are talking debate this for this
matter.
>> And it is he's saying something. I I'm
not I'm not keep memorizing the the
words he's saying, but I'm sure 100
versions he's saying by the name of
Allah.
>> No, brother. Look, let me help you cuz I
read the B I read the whole Bible. I
read it every day.
>> Oh, and I'm reading the Quran every
single day.
>> So, so look, I'm saying in the Bible
Jesus when he does a miracle, he doesn't
say in the name of Allah. When he does a
miracle, he just does it. He just does
the miracle.
>> Well, well, when Quran, it says
>> by permission of Allah.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Saying that and and this things. But
let's talk about similarity sim similar
to to these things.
>> Okay, let's talk about similar Moses.
>> Huh? Moses.
>> What about Moses?
>> What what he's done for for to to to
believe in Allah. He he done a lot of
miracles
he's done.
>> Yeah. But but was that Moses doing that
or was that God doing that?
>> That Moses doing it by the help of God.
But Moses Allah Allah subhanaa tala he's
telling Moses okay do and he will do it.
Okay that is gave a sign for us as a
human being. Okay telling us okay this
guy here has a miracles because Allah
God he's held a lot there's a there's a
there's a slight misunderstanding
>> giving the permission to do this.
>> I understand what you're saying there.
There's a slight misunderstanding here
though. Moses when he went to Pharaoh
Moses didn't do anything.
>> What he did? The only thing he did,
look, he had a staff in his hand.
>> He hit the
>> He had a st Yeah. He hit He hit the He
hit the water and then God turned the
water into blood.
>> By the name of God.
>> No, God did it. He look He said He says,
"I'm going to I'm going to do it."
>> Let's Let's be honest with you.
>> I am. That's what I'm saying. There's
There's nothing in the Quran that says
Moses did.
>> You are trying to con to to convince me
for something you
>> I'm I'm only saying what the Quran and
the Bible say.
>> Okay. When I'm telling you what the
Quran saying.
>> So, okay. One day, one day after nothing
in the Quran says that Moses did the
sign, brother.
>> Nothing in the Quran says Moses did the
sign. It says Allah did it. Nothing in
the Quran says Moses did it.
>> No. Quran is saying he's asked when when
when he was running away from with with
the Jewish people, his people, okay,
because they're going to be killed by
Feron, okay? And his army,
>> okay? And he heading to uh away from
Fon. He found the servant of him there's
no way to go and he said Allah what can
I do and he asked M said m take your
stick and hit okay and things will be a
rude rude for you
>> yes okay that's what does it mean who's
done the the the but the one the sea
right
>> he's able to do whatever to do
>> good the same thing
>> there's a difference with Jesus
>> no that's not different
>> yes it is
>> believe me it's not
>> it is Jesus never says Allah help me do
this. He never says this.
>> Believe me, it's the same. Why? Because
Allah subhana tala
>> when he created Jesus, he created
through the virgin.
>> What does it have to do with Jesus
performing miracles under his on his by
his power?
>> No, I'm telling you. Let me continue.
>> This is why when he burn from the
without father, okay, and he giving that
the power to Jesus. Okay, it doesn't say
that. And you guys, you guys believe in
that Jesus is killed.
>> Wait, just just really quick. It doesn't
say that Allah gave him power.
>> It is.
>> The Quran doesn't say that.
>> You want to I could give you a Quran.
You can show me the verse. Where does
the Quran say that?
>> Okay.
>> You speak Arabic?
>> I speak Arabic.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Where where does the Quran say
that Allah gave Jesus power?
>> Yeah. See,
>> I think you would go to Surah Imm,
right?
Now, if you say permission, I think
that's a different thing cuz he does
give him permission to do things, but
giving him power to do things is two
different things.
>> Wait, wait, wait, let me see that.
[Music]
See here what it say.
Huh? Translate for me. Yeah.
>> What verse is that?
>> Yeah.
>> Is that this?
>> Yes. See what it say?
>> On the day when Allah will gather the
messengers together and ask, "What was
the response
uh you received?"
And they will say, "We have no
knowledge. It is you who knows in full
all that is hidden."
>> Oh Jesus.
>> Okay.
>> The son of Mary.
Recount recount my favor to you and to
your mother. Behold, I strengthen you
with the Holy Spirit so that you did
speak to the people in childhood and in
old age. Behold, I taught you the book
and wisdom.
>> So, but what about the miracles he did
about this is this is this is this is
this is it says clearly this is when you
say I'm helping you here. I help you
with the Holy Spirit. Which is see this
is the miracle. This is the miracle
here. See He was just fine.
He's saying Allah subhana ta God he's
talking to Isa. Oh Isa Oh Jesus
gave you a whole things to make you
create from the from the dust.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Okay.
>> The evening by permission of me.
>> Yes. uh uh to make like uh to make a
bird with clay and
even
by my permission. That's what I'm
telling you.
>> Okay. So, let me ask you this. Let's
let's think about this. I understand
what you're saying. Now, there's a
difference between permission, right?
Giving permission and then also giving
power or ability. For example, um are
these your daughters here? All right.
Can they drive? Do they know how to
drive?
>> No.
>> Okay. They don't know how to drive.
Okay. So, let's say um one day you tell
one of your daughters, you say, "Hey,
I'm giving you permission to drive my
car. Here are the keys." You know, you
hand them the keys. You say, "Here's
permission to drive my car." Right.
>> But she doesn't know how to drive yet.
She doesn't have the ability to. Right.
So, just because you gave her nothing.
>> Exactly.
>> Even if they have the key.
>> Exactly. Okay. What's the point? So the
so the point is is that just because you
give your daughter permission, it
doesn't mean that you give her the
power, the ability to drive, right?
>> Agree.
>> Okay. So with Jesus, for example,
>> wait a minute. Wait, I'm close. I'm so
close. I'm so close.
>> Okay. Go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead.
>> Okay. So, all right. So with Allah and
Jesus, right? So Allah with Jesus, he
gave him permission to create the bird,
right? But it doesn't say that he gave
Jesus power to create the bird from
clay. Meaning that Jesus already had the
power to create the bird, but he only
did it when Allah said, "Okay, you can
go ahead and do it with his permission."
You understand what I'm saying?
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> Let me tell you something. Okay.
>> When you're saying now for the key, if I
give my my daughters the key and they
they don't know how to drive,
>> okay, they will do nothing because they
do know how to drive, right? But if I
take them to teach them how to drive and
I give them the key, they will be able.
What does it mean that? That mean I get
them the key. I give them the permission
to use my car. In the same time, I'm
helping them how to drive. It's the same
with Jesus.
>> But it it doesn't say that.
>> It says I show it to clearly my friend.
>> Okay. About creating the bird.
>> No. No. I I I saw it to you.
>> Uh sorry.
>> We have to be honest with each other.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I told you I told you
here tonight I'm not here. See this it's
big chap only talking about Mary
>> uh it talks about a bunch of stuff it's
different but yeah I understand
>> sariam is about
[Applause]
this night
where is Finish this.
You're close.
Where?
>> What the I'm getting confused. Where
>> am I? Where's your mic?
>> Where am I? Uh,
>> listen. I know.
>> There it is. Here. See what it says?
And I teach you
here. It says I teach you one. Yeah.
And he said
>> he says he teach him the book and the
wisdom and stuff
>> by my permission the evening by my
permission.
>> Yes. But now does it say that he Yeah, I
understand.
>> If he didn't give him he cannot
>> wait the bar he will not have it.
>> Okay. So so for example now if um let's
say let's say me cuz I I know how to
drive. Okay. Let's say that you um
didn't give me permission to drive your
car,
>> right? But if I if I stole your keys, I
could drive your car anyway, right?
>> That's something different,
>> right? So what I'm saying is is that
permission giving permission
>> is is different from giving power and
ability. You know, I'm saying that here
>> that that's that's bro that's your
understanding.
>> Okay.
>> I respect it.
>> But my understanding it says no, it's
not the way you are understanding.
>> Okay. So all right, you get me?
>> Fair enough. Fair enough. I'm just
saying that from the Quran. I'm praying
to Allah to to to help me to see the
truth and
>> I I'm asking Allah to help me to see the
truth and you ask the Jesus to show me
the truth.
>> Yes.
>> And we'll see.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah. Of course. Have a good day. That's
a nice
>> twice and we'll think about it.
>> Yeah. Both of us.
>> Okay. Mah you have you have the the the
Holy Quran.
>> Yes.
>> I read it. I read the whole thing.
>> Yeah.
>> Have you read Have you read the Gospel
The No, I don't have it. You have it?
Give it to me. Do we have a do we have a
Bible we can give him?
>> Wait,
>> one day you'll be Muslim, bro. I know.
>> No, you don't say I know too much.
>> All even though
>> I'm a Christian.
>> I I respect you. We are respecting. See,
we are Thank you very much. Thank you,
bro.
>> Thank you.
>> We are respecting all Christian. We are
respecting all Jews. We are respecting
even the Buddhist
>> as a Muslims. We are respecting them.
Oh, but it doesn't mean we are not
saying okay uh everyone here has knows
everything. Maybe you know that you know
everything but maybe you missed
something a little.
>> Can I tell you can I can I tell you my
biggest thing on why I'm not Muslim.
Okay. My my biggest thing is that the
Quran talks about the previous
scriptures, right? The Torah and the
Injil, right, which I read. And so it
says that um Muhammad can be found in
the Torah and the Gospel. Right now, I
read the Torah and Gospel. It's my book.
I read it every day. I read it. It's my
life. Right?
>> And I don't see Muhammad's description
or mention in it. No, it's not there.
>> Give me your phone.
>> Okay.
>> Give me your phone. Give me your number.
>> Give me your number. I'll send it to
you.
>> Okay.
>> I'll you clearly give me your number,
please, with your mic.
>> I'll show it to you clearly.
>> Okay. You know Ahmed Dat?
>> Yes, I know Ahmed Dat I've seen I've
seen his videos.
>> Ser himself, he cannot defeat it. My
friend
>> Zak. Yeah,
>> you you think Zakanak is good.
>> I I don't know. It's good or not.
>> But I'm telling you, he debates with a
lot of people.
>> Yeah, but not not knowledgeable. Not
knowledgeable.
>> They are not my friend. They are one of
the famous of Christian. You know that.
>> No, he he he won't debate debaters like
like real debaters. Christian debator.
>> What's your number?
>> I'll put it in.
>> I'll give you a ring. I'll send you a
WhatsApp. Okay. Evie, nice to meet you.
>> Nice to meet you, too, brother.
>> I have to be in touch.
>> Yeah.
>> One of us will be
>> Mother.
>> Okay.
>> God bless you, brother.
>> Oh my god.
>> Magic.
[Music]